eight news now all right we all know how
challenging it can be when it comes time
to filling up our gas tank well the
golden knights teamed up with smith's to
give 800 drivers free gas this morning
it happened at the smithson sky canyon
joe moeller reports people lined up
early
businesses now back to usual here at
this gas station some were waiting since
2 am they say these prices are worth the
wait
it seems every day we wake up and gas is
up another few cents the drivers in line
for free gas thursday is proof that the
rising prices are impacting all of us
the vegas golden knights and smiths
teamed up to give out 40 thousand
dollars worth of gas to 800 drivers
starting at 8 this morning each driver
getting 50 bucks of gas people arrived
way before the sun was up some sleeping
in their cars drivers i spoke with say
the weight was worth it this is going to
help me immensely
immensely because i think ride share
drivers both uber and lyft have been hit
hardest because gas is
our life gas is one of the main things i
need right now and i appreciate it go go
the nights this isn't the first time
knights have given out gas they held a
similar event in april some nights and
people from the team also showed up the
deal is not over here just yet you can
still get 20 cents off per gallon today
and tomorrow reporting in sky canyon joe
muller live local now
all right